mise à jour économique aujourd'hui au
Québec on a fait le point sur les
finances publiques sur le solde
budgétaire et on annonçait des nouvelles
des parents cerejeira sera avec nous
dans une seconde je voudrais ce
rapidement le tableau de ce qui a été
annoncé
oui la croissance de l'économie du
Québec
16,5 pourcents de croissance du PIB en
2021 au Canada c'est 5,5 + le Canada en
22 ans on prévoit
3,3 et 4 au Canada donc ça ça permet ça
permet donc de diminuer le déficit prévu
7,5 ans 20 21 21 22 6,8 et 5,8 milliards
donc on se dirige tranquillement ça
prendre un peu plus longtemps que prévu
on se dirige tranquillement vers une
équilibre budgétaire
annonce et donc contenu de l'argent qui
rentre et c'est des nouvelles pour les
couples 400 dollars des gens qui font
moins de 50000 dollars par année ça
touche le 3 million et plus de Québécois
275 dollars personnes vivant seule d'un
chat qui va arriver dans prochain et 200
dollars personne seule vivent en
colocation ou tu as des nouvelles des
pense qu'on a annoncé pour 13 milliards
coût de la vie on vient de le dire aider
les gens qui recevra un chèque main
d'oeuvre on va par exemple envoyer on va
par exemple envoyer des de l'argent à
des étudiants dans des programmes où on
a besoin de temps c'est la santé penser
à des techniques informatique aide aux
familles 3,1 milliards c'est beaucoup
les garderie et le système de santé on
va dépenser plus au cours des prochaines
années 4,4 milliards de plus soit c'est
des nouvelles dépenses le ministre des
Finances est avec nous à Eric Girard
bonsoir bonsoir bon j'ai raison
rapidement mais disant que le point de
départ de l'histoire c'est que
l'économie roule plus vite qu'on croyait
c'est une performance exceptionnelle le
Québec fait mieux en 2021 que le Canada
et les États-Unis que la moyenne
mondiale alors on a récupéré le niveau
de croissance que nous avions avant la
pandémie dès le mois de juillet 2021 qui
vous permet
c' est prévue voulais réduisez de plus
de 5 milliards qui était prévu
c'est
l'année courant mais ce qui est
important de dire c'est que l'ensemble
de
6 milliards sur l'horizon c'est 6
milliards
3 milliards on met pour réduire le
déficit structurel parce que je suis à
la pandémie et on investit 3 milliards
avec les moyens que les la force
d'économie ne donne pas de nouvelles des
parents ce que vous annoncer
que vous avez envoyé vous êtes avoir
touché 3,5 million de Québécois dis-moi
toute personne qui est éligible au
crédit d'impôt sur le
revenu
par personne vivant seule c'est une
prestation prestation exceptionnelle une
fois en janvier 2022 pour compenser la
hausse du coût de la vie qui est réelle
et les gens en ont besoin et on vient
donner un coup de pouce en janvier 2022
exactement prestation exceptionnelle
sac à dos je dirais pas que c'est un
cadeau parce que la session lorsqu'on
regarde la période 2122 ou 4 pourcents
moyen de déclaration le régime fiscal de
deux. Alors ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
vient la différence entre 4 et de
la Solidarité sociale
[Musique]
promis par le gouvernement libéral donc
plus d'argent pour les places en
garderie est-ce que on voit la
concrétisation de ça et qu'est-ce que ça
donne dans les faits un nombre de place
avec le gouvernement fédéral si
on a une entente avec le gouvernement
fédéral que j'ai personnellement
négocier avec
très bien le le système de santé vous
ajouter de l'argent galvaplast indiquer
pour aider à
accélérer le rattrapage dans les
opérations concrètement ils vont où cet
argent la
chirurgie qu'on veut
et
qui
sont
mais ça dès que je te le problème qui
structurel qu'on doit attaquer de
plusieurs façons alors on l'attaque avec
la formation la diplômation mais aussi
la requalification parce que même moment
qu'on ne 200000 postes vacants 250.000
chômage
étudiant étranger les travailleurs
étrangers
construction
bien on pense que on parle ça va marcher
on pense qu'il y aura beaucoup beaucoup
de clients de
d'étudiants mais lorsqu'on dépense de 9
milliards de dollars en pense que ça va
marcher
on
emploie
est-ce que ça va
désintégrer la société et en même temps
de la demande du des employeurs du
marché du travail alors 50000 dollars
50000 personnes excusez-moi
très bien on vous a aussi donné un autre
responsabilité la semaine dernière entre
publiquement moi je sais tout faire pour
faire revenir les Nordiques à Québec
c'est quoi le plan de match
d'abord plan de match puis-je content de
voir
tout le monde alors je pense que s'il y
a une chose à retenir de ce qui s'est
passé la dernière semaine c'est que les
gens sont intéressés c'est un beau
projet faut d'abord comprendre pourquoi
on est une équipe d'expansion une équipe
il faut comprendre
envoie-le
sur le la Vendée pingouin
plus d'un million de dollars une
franchise
le Québec
et comprendre qu'est-ce que ça prend
pour avoir une équipe mais lui il va
vous dire est-ce que vous avez une
entreprise un gros prêt à mettre un
milliard Obama et est-ce que vous allez
jouer un rôle dans un état rentre par
exemple Pierre Karl Péladeau à Québec
qui est intéressé dans l'ensemble
Vidéotron à Québec de mettre une équipe
et d'autre parce que on imagine ne
peuvent plus le faire seul en fait
partie la solution
personnellement monsieur
un propriétaire
est-ce que une solution comme le partage
qui est envisagée pour les les expos et
les
partager
[Musique]
pour
créer un groupe
pour qu'elle pourrait se joindre à
Monsieur peladeau est-ce que déjà vous
êtes un démarchage vous me vous me
surprenez par le nombre de questions ce
sujet mais
[Musique]
pour
plusieurs entreprises
patron Camila rondelles au jus et qui
vous a voulu qu'on parle de ça je vous
ai jamais posé des questions sur les
Nordiques en temps normal mais alors
j'essaie de voir dans quelle mesure si
sérieux cette perspective du retour
d'une équipe est dans quel quel rôle le
gouvernement et vous en particulier
aller jouer dans tout ça mais on va on
va suivre ça se Gérard l'an prochain si
si l'économie
se met un peu à ralentir est-ce que vos
prévisions de dépenses tiennent la route
pour la fourchette prévision du secteur
privé alors on est conservateur
nouvelles mesures environnementales j'en
ai cherché j'en ai pas trouvé mais c'est
parce que mon mon collègue a présenté le
plan quinquennal 6 - 5 milliards sur 50
et il est révisé à chaque année ce sera
budget
faire des révisions mais certainement
qu'il y en aura
au revoir